Mohammed decides to record the count
the leaves of the tree in his backyard every year.
In the first year it had 500 sheets.
Every year the number of leaves
was 40% more than the previous one.
Let n be a positive integer and let f be a n denote
the number of leaves in the backyard of Mohammed
during the nth year after he started tracking them.
The expression f of n specifies a number.
What kind of array is f of n?
So, some of you
they can think right away.
Each year the number increases by 40%,
which is the same as the multiplication of 1.4.
Every successive period is multiplied
or divide into the same number.
This will be a geometrical progression.
Let's make it clear a little more,
just in case.
Let's make a small table here.
This is n, and this is f of n.
When n equals 1,
the first year n is equal to 1,
there were 500 sheets, or f of n is 500.
When n equals 2, we will have
an increase of 40%,
which is the same as the multiplication of 1.4.
500 by 1.4, with 40% of 500 being 200,
the number will increase by 200,
therefore we will have 700.
In the third year we will increase by 40% to 700,
which is 280, so we will have 980 sheets.
Note that this is definitely not an arithmetic progression.
We add an arithmetic progression
or subtract the same amount each time,
but now we do not.
Here, from 500 to 700, we have an increase of 200,
then from 700 to 980 we have an increase of 280.
We multiply or divide by
the same quantity each time.
In this case we multiply by 1.4 each time.
Therefore, we definitely have a geometric progression.
Depending on your answer to the question above,
the recurrent definition of the row
may have one of the following two forms.
This is a good arithmetic form
we know we do not have in this case, so we will
we have the geometric shape.
And then he asks what the values ​​are
of parameters A and B for the row?
So here's the base case,
f of n is equal to A when n equals 1.
We know that when n equals 1,
we had 500 leaves on the tree,
so this A here is 500.
A is 500.
Then, if we are not in the base case,
for each next year we have, let's see,
we have the previous year multiplied by what?
We will have the previous year, up 40%.
To increase by 40%, multiply by 1.4,
so B will be 1.4.
You take the previous year and multiply
1.4 for each subsequent year,
for each year other than n equal to 1.
So, B equals 1.4 and we are ready.
Let's figure out another example.
This is funny.
Okay, here it says: Siu-Yun organizes a party.
She has a 50 party gift to hand out and
gives 3 gifts to each guest
at the time of their arrival.
Let n be a positive integer and let g of n denote
the number of party gifts that Sio-Yun has
before the nth guest arrives.
Well, actually, even before we even look at these questions,
let's draw a table here because it says
before the nth guest.
I want to make sure I understand it correctly.
So it's n
and then it will be g of n,
right here.
When n is equal to 1, g of n is,
or g of 1 is the number of party gifts,
which Sio-Yun had before the first guest.
Well, before the first guest she had a 50 party gift.
She had 50 gifts for the party.
Now, the second guest comes.
The number of gifts she has before the second guest,
she had to give 3 to the first,
so now there will be 47 gifts.
When n equals 3,
how much a party present she has
before the third guest?
He had to give gifts
the first and second guest, each receiving 3.
So now there will be 44 and I think you notice the regularity.
When n is equal to 1, g of n is 50
and every time we increase n by 1.
Every time we increase n, we increase g by n with plus 3,
I had to say minus 3,
because she gives gifts to the party, so minus 3.
Because the difference between successive members
is the same, we know that this is an arithmetical progression.
This is an arithmetical progression and should
to write the formula for explicit set of the row.
Let's think about it.
Let's say g of n will be equal to ...
Let's see, we'll start at 50,
then we take out 3 and let us think,
whether we get 3 in n or whether ...?
Let's see the first guest
we pulled out 3 times.
For the second guest we remove 3 once.
For the third guest we draw 3 times.
For the nth guest we will draw 3 n minus 1 times.
Notice, for the 3rd guest we pulled out 3 times.
The second guest - we pulled out 3 times.
The first guest - we pulled out 3 times,
so this is so.
For the first guest we will draw 3 zero times
and so g of 1 will be 50.
We can see that this is consistent for all of these.
So I can write 50 minus 3 minus n minus 1,
by really recommending making the table,
just to make sure you get n minus 1
or n properly, and that's all.